Hunter Biden a man who has documented
terabytes worth of his own crimes across
at least five criminal categories on at
least three different continents has
finally been indicted has hell frozen
over are pigs flying oh contr mon frer
it is just business as usual because
these charges are nothing but a
misdirection you see Hunter is not being
charged with tax fraud which he
committed but which could implicate his
father and he isn't being charged with
failing to register as a foreign agent
another crime he committed that could
also implicate his father and he isn't
being charged with smoking crack and
abusing hookers in just about every
corner of the globe crimes that he most
certainly committed and which don't
directly implicate his father but which
nevertheless reflect quite poorly on the
first son and the Biden family no no he
is being charged with lying on some
paperwork work when purchasing a firearm
that is to say he's charged with making
too expansive a use of his second
amendment rights rights cherished by
Americans since long before the nation's
founding and defended especially by
Biden's most trenchant critics he's
being charged with the crime least
significant least damaging to his father
and most likely to elicit
sympathy this is not quite the political
Master stroke that Biden's doj thought
it had with that sweetheart plea deal to
let Hunter off the hook entirely which
ultimately was undermined by a judge who
laughed it out of the courtroom but this
is pretty
close now these gun charges do still
theoretically carry with them the
prospect of something like 25 years in
prison but that's obviously never going
to happen Joe Biden will under no
circumstances allow his last living son
son to rot in prison even if Hunter Were
Somehow convicted the indictment is a
limited Hangout to get the heat off the
big guy until he makes it through his
next election nothing more nothing less
I'm Michael nlls this is the Michael
nlls
[Music]
Show
welcome back to the show this episode is
brought to you by good ranchers get
great meat at a secure price and 25
bucks off your order with code nolles
klees go to good ranchers.com use code
nolles K wle
today Dove the company Dove that makes
soap and shampoo is partnering with a
fat Liberation activist who hoaxed her
way into to destroying some poor college
girls life who has a very very checkered
past and this is par for the course for
liberalism we'll get to that in a moment
first though speaking of prosecutions of
leading political figures and their
families and
Associates Donald Trump will not stand
trial next month you know I hate to say
I Told You So in this case I really love
to say I told you so it was announced
some weeks ago that amid all of these
indictments with Trump trump was going
to stand trial in o October of 2023 and
I said that's absolutely Preposterous
this was the Georgia prosecutor who was
pushing for this speedy trial I said
what are you talking about you got the
former president current leader of the
opposition you've got 18 codefendants on
this ridiculous unprecedented sort of
case you think that you're going to get
get your trials together within two
months not a chance in hell and that's
the case so this is good news for Trump
in that he's not going to deal have to
deal with this trial as he continues
along his way to secure the nomination
which right now looks pretty
secure now don't don't shoot the
messenger if you like one of the other
candidates I'm just saying right now
Trump's poll numbers not only have
remained the same they've actually gone
up a little bit the latest poll we've
got from Fox News shows that Donald
Trump is at
60% among Republican primary voters
Trump's at 60 DeSantis who's the number
two guy is at 133
VI who has jumped up in the polls number
three guy close at to sanz's heels he's
at 11 Nikki Haley has helped herself
she's at five pence three Scott three
chrisy two so that that's a huge huge
spread this is a 47-point lead right now
for Trump uh but but also what's
interesting is the movement here so we
were told that not showing up to the
debate was going to be disastrous for
Donald Trump and you were going to see
that the other guys especially Dan
santis were going to jump up in the
polls and as a result of that Trump was
going to have to show up to the second
debate and I said yeah look if if Dan
santis jumps in the polls then Trump
will show up to the second debate but I
actually don't think it's going to hurt
him I think not showing up to the debate
is going to help him and that would
appear to be the case since August uh
Trump is now up seven points from where
he in August he was at 53% according to
this poll now he's at 60% since August
DeSantis is down three points even
though he did Rel relatively well he did
fine in the debate down three points V
is even so V some people thought V did
really well in the debate some people
were really turned off by him so
whatever I guess that shakes up to be
he's even with where he was Nikki has
gone up one point uh Pence has gone down
two points despite a relatively strong
debate performance Tim Scotts remain the
same christe the chiss assant the
croissant would seem to be over that is
down one the other graph I want to point
to is not just this one random Fox News
pole but rular politics is average of
all the polls going all the way back to
July of last
year th this is the
primary and you can see there's some ups
and downs a little bit Trump is up a
little bit from where he started last
July Dan santis is down a little bit
from where he started last July and then
V jumped up because no one knew who he
was before but still not he didn't jump
up that far relative to where he was he
jumped up very far but relative to the
race he didn't and but
basically nothing has
changed nothing despite the hundreds of
millions of dollars raised despite all
of the ads despite all of the campaign
teams assembled despite all of the
canvasing door Todo despite all of the
online social media operations rapid
response directing
PE none of it has mattered at all so I
don't don't shoot the messenger I I'm
not saying give up hope look some
something could happen
if you support a disantis or a v or one
of the other candidates
but regardless of this race showing you
that Trump is just really really strong
or that DeSantis is not as good a
candidate as they said he was or V is
the game changer or this that or the
other thing take the candidates out of
it for a second it's just not really a
dynamic race I guess that's the issue we
think it's a dynamic race because you've
got
this wild eccentric character in Donald
Trump who's being indicted as a former
president leader of the opposition for
the first time ever oh my goodness four
indictments all over the country this is
crazy we've never seen anything like it
and then we've got Ronda santis this
very strong very popular governor in
Florida who's taking the Republican
party in some ways in a New Direction
and or at least building on the previous
president Donald Trump and then you got
this guy oh man it's going to be so
Dynamic 10 candidates isn't this no it's
not it's not because the leader of the
pack is running effectively practically
mostly as an incumbent and so the race
is going to be more Dynamic than George
Bush's primary primary race which
essentially didn't exist in
2004 it's going to be more Dynamic than
Barack Obama's primary race in
2012 but it's going to be much much less
Dynamic than any other kind of primary
the the question if you are one of the
other campaigns or if you're the Trump
campaign for that matter that you've got
to ask now is what could happen to
change this graph which has remained
relatively unchanged for 14 months we
got to talk about that the campaigns are
certainly all going to be talking about
that when you want to talk to your
friends you got to check out P talk
right now go to Pur talk.com you know a
company's looking at for you when they
upgrade your service and don't charge
you for it this is great news for new
and current Pure Talk customers pure
talk just added data to every plan and
includes a mobile hotspot with no price
increase whatsoever if you you
considered pure talk before but haven't
made the switch take a look again for
just 20 bucks a month you will get
unlimited talk text and now 550% more 5G
data plus their new mobile hotspot this
is why I love Pure Talk they're
veteran-owned they only hire the best
customer service team it's located right
here in the USA that alone is worth
switching over most families are saving
almost $1,000 a year while enjoying the
most Dependable 5G Network in America
remember you vote with how you spend
your money so stop supporting woke
wireless companies that don't support
you when you go to PE talk.com noes you
will save an additional 5050 z% off your
first month because they value you go to
Pur talk.com Pure Talk Wireless by
Americans for
Americans elections do matter though
elections really really matter because
forget about the politicians now for a
second I want to turn my attention to
Planned
Parenthood Planned Parenthood has
suffered massive massive
layoffs less than two weeks before the
anniversary of the uh decision in dobs
to overrule roie Wade this two weeks
before according to the Boston
Globe uh more than 100 employees of
planned parenthood's National staff
received notice that they would lose
their jobs why are they losing their
jobs is it because donations to plan
Parenthood dried up no donations to plan
Parenthood spiked after that was a major
historic fundraising opportunity for
Planned Parenthood they took advantage
of it every big lib in the country was
saying give your money to Planned
Parenthood so they had the
money but demand cratered they no longer
had the customers they no longer had
quite so many mothers coming in saying
hey I'm in a desperate situation and
then these Predators at Planned
Parenthood say oh I've got the answer
murder your baby and give us a little
bit of money for it too we'll we'll do
the hit job if you just pay us that's
the
problem it was not a matter of funding
it was not a matter of investment it was
a matter of demand demand totally
cratered and here's what the what the
staffers are saying and telling the
Boston Globe planed Parenthood said the
pivot was necessary to meet this moment
after dos but the staffers who requested
anonymity due to the sensitivity of the
subject matter often described
disillusionment with the organization
they included Union and non-union
workers some who had been laid off or
left for other reasons as well as some
who are still working there they're
they're disillusioned you know turns out
that when you work for an infanticide
Mill it's not all it's cracked up to be
uh you know I thought we were working
with people with Integrity here I
thought we were signing up with
high-minded noble people who make it
their mission in life to slaughter the
most innocent vulnerable persons on
planet Earth and then what do you know
they're kind of deceitful could you
imagine they don't they don't have the
strongest moral code those
professional murderers of babies the the
article goes on plant Parenthood
struggles with the right level of
transparency said another National
staffer who was laid off it felt like
they were trying to give us a lot of
transparency about the process like
we're making this pivot these are some
of the things that are changing but
there wasn't a lot of transparency
around like the vision and where things
were going based on those
changes Planned Parenthood is so opposed
to transparency that
Lobby against laws that would make women
who are about to murder their babies
look at
ultrasounds if you are looking for
transparency I would not recommend
looking at Planned Parenthood the entire
business model of which relies on hiding
and disguising the fact that your baby
is actually a baby the whole business
model relies on on distracting you from
seeing what is obviously true so that
they can make money money and get
whatever satanic kicks they get out of
murdering little
children you're not going to get
transparency there you're not going to
get high-minded idealism you're not
going to get Noble comportment and
behavior and now you're apparently not
going to get a
job this is a great story because it
proves something that conservatives did
not believe for far too long which is
that we we long have said politics is
Downstream of culture the movies in a
culture the music the art the the
behavior the Traditions the rituals that
all matters of course that all
matters but it can be said with just as
much seriousness and truth that culture
is Downstream of politics because the
law is a teacher what happened
here what happened here is not that
people got together and they just had a
change of heart
organically from the culture and society
and so they decided to stop killing
their children it's that the heavy hand
of the law came down and made it much
more difficult to murder children and
then fewer people did it that's what
happened you know sometimes we've been
told by the politics this Downstream of
culture Fanatics the who make an idol
out of that concept that actually if you
pass a law that's not going to change
anything at all no no the law doesn't
affect Behavior the law doesn't create
incentives no no unless the the change
in law is motivated by just a change in
culture which Springs up organically
from the society then it's not going to
have any effect at all well here's proof
that that's a lie that isn't true you
can change the law even if the culture
which is completely dominated by
liberals in Hollywood in the academy in
lower education in everything everywhere
you can change the law you will still
get that effect Planned Parenthood is
still going to have to lay off workers
because fewer fewer women are going to
show up to murder their babies because
the law says so and the law is a
teacher what liberalism does Classical
liberalism and libertarianism and modern
liberalism and all of its derivations
what it does is it tries to depoliticize
everything so it creates these these
contrasts between you know politics and
culture the the law the government and
society and free associations but we
live in a republic we live in government
of the People by the people for the
people at least in
theory so what's really the difference
between those two things that that
distinction gets a little bit blurry it
gets a lot blurry actually and really
that what that distinction serves to do
is is a merely a polemical purpose to
discourage authentic political action
and to disguise authentic political
action under the guise of it being
depoliticized through the economy or
just through private business or just
through the culture do you really
believe this is what some of these
people would say they would say that
when Google Twitter and Facebook
completely dominate the Public Square
and cut out conservatives from speaking
and censor all sorts of ordinary things
and true things even right before an
election they censor the hunter Biden
laptop story and it changes the results
of the election according to
postelection analysis and surveys but
what what these types of people will say
is well that wasn't a political action
that was just private Enterprise that
was just private businesses doing
whatever they want to do that's not
political and if you don't like it build
your own Google build your own Twitter
what are you talking about we live in a
a self-governing republic if you can
control the the Public Square you
control the political order what Google
Twitter and Facebook did is intensely
political it's some of the most overt
heavy-handed political action I've ever
seen in my lifetime maybe in the history
of the United States and it's even more
Insidious than some
authoritarian government worker doing so
because Facebook Twitter and Google have
even less accountability even less
transparency and they're not obliged to
uphold the principles that we have
passed that our our for forbears have
passed and ratified into law the
protections of the Constitution and laws
in many
cases uh-uh the law is a teacher baby it
works and it has real crucial urgent
effects it saves hundreds of it's saved
hundreds of thousands of babies lives
there will be hundreds of thousands of
people from this year alone who will be
born
because some justices on the Supreme
Court decided to change the law culture
be damned no actually culture be changed
for the better because the culture is
affected by the laws okay speaking of
electoral
politics we are losing one of
the most controversial detested but
sometimes lauded but just very confusing
political
figures Mitt
Romney I've spent my last 25 years in
public service of one kind or another at
the end of another term I'd be in my mid
80s frankly it's time for a new
generation of leaders they're the ones
that need to make the decisions that
will shape the world they will be living
in now we Face critical challenges Ming
national debt climate change and the
ambitious authoritarians of Russia and
China neither President Biden nor former
president Trump are leading their party
to confront those
issues you know my views on Mitt Romney
see he seems like a nice enough guy but
he's a liberal Republican Mitt Romney
runs for Senate against Ted Kennedy in
Massachusetts and he says I I was
independent during the time of Reagan
Bush I don't support Reagan Bush I'm not
stop lumping me in with Ronald Reagan
and then he loses that race and he goes
on and he runs for governor of
Massachusetts and wins that and invents
Obamacare and then he runs for president
on not a great campaign then he decides
to run for well he doesn't decide to run
against Trump in 2016 he entertained the
thought of running but he he was pretty
active as a never Trumper and trying to
kill the Republican ticket that year
then he runs for Senate in another state
he wins he's a big lib in the Senate
okay I've got problems with his career
and yet gotta say
folks he's totally right with what he
just said he's totally right when he
says we need a new generation of
conservative leaders you know me I'm not
like some of my friends and colleagues
I'm not one to mock people for being old
I don't think that we need age limits
for government office I think we we have
the only limit we need which is The
Ballot Box when The Ballot Box Works
effectively uh I'm I I think that
generally older people are wiser than
younger people I don't however we do
need a new generation of leaders the
Boomers have been hanging on for a very
very long time a disproportionately long
time compared to past Generations when
the sea change happens it's going to be
more radical the longer this goes on and
uh that does threaten the stability of
the country and also
we have seen in the one country in the
west that has been able to affect real
conservative policies and stop some of
the most pressing issues the migration
crisis being right there up toward the
top of them and also to turn around the
birth rate problem which is the crisis
as a matter of policy in our
civilization that country is a young
government okay you need a new
generation because while the the
previous uh View View and talking points
and ideologies maybe they served a
purpose for their time maybe they did
some good stuff in their time I'm not
knocking the pre prior Generations but
now we've got we've got new problems and
young people you even see them popping
up in in the Senate they've got new
Solutions applying Eternal principles to
new circumstances that's great the irony
of this is what Mitt Romney is saying
here is we need a new generation of
conservative leaders but then he goes on
to attack all the young conservatives he
attacks JD Vance he attacks Jos hly
attacks Ted Cruz he he attacks the
people who actually are younger and and
are much uh more effective I think in in
their vision for the country so he
Romney personally he's still got a lot
of problems in his his understanding of
politics but on this point mitt is
totally right speaking of younger when
you want to look younger you got to
check out Jus cell right now go to
genucell.com as you might know we are
big fans of our friends over at genell
especially the the founder who's a
Coptic Christian from Egypt who fled and
came over here for the American dream
their product is fabulous don't take my
word for it Ella from Rockford says
quote I have both age and acne spots and
this stuff is actually fading both of
them this Serum is worth every penny
Ella is raving about the famous Dark
Spot Corrector from Jus cell a musthave
after months of record heat and humidity
sunspots brown spots discoloration even
red inflamed patches all disappear in
front of your very eyes here's the genu
cell amazing guarantee you will see
results on day one or your money back if
it happens on day two you can get your
money back take advantage of genus
cell's most popular package which now
includes the Dark Spot Corrector plus
the classic genus cell eye bags and
puffiness treatment with immediate
effects all at about 70 70% off right
now go to genucell.com
slns start looking years even decades
younger tomorrow say goodbye to dark and
liver spots bags and puffiness under the
eyes and crows feet at Jus cell.com that
is Jus cell.com
slns my favorite comment yesterday is
from Billy Mays one Billy Mays here who
says if Michael ever ran for pus he
would have my vote no doubt about it
America needs to be safe thank you very
much I appreciate that there's a little
wrinkle here which is that I am
currently too young to run for president
I would be constitutionally ineligible
in 2024 the first time that I would be
even eligible constitutionally will be
2028 but if Republicans lose this
election then we of course will be in
the ggs by that time so I suppose I
could run for president of the Googs
it's like it's like running for class
president but in prison and maybe I will
do that and if I do I appreciate your
support and I appreciate your your
vote speaking of young people Dove the
soap company has just partnered with a
young activist this young activist's
name is Zion Anna Bryant and if you've
heard that name before you might vaguely
remember this person it's because she
made a little bit of a name for herself
by ruining a young white student's life
over a misheard remark at some BLM
protest in 2020 so there was some mostly
mostly peaceful extremely fiery BLM
protest and this gal Zion Brian who is
Black said that she heard this this
young woman uh say that the protesters
would make good effing speed
bumps that never happened there were
investigations into this there was Zero
evidence there is significant evidence
that this Zana Bryant just completely
made it up there is no evidence that
this young gal this UVA student Morgan
beninger ever said anything even like
that but it didn't matter
because the damage was done falsehood
flies while
the truth is getting out of bed so over
a year years of this young gal's life
were ruined by this cynical activist xan
Bryant who was lying and now she's got a
a new object of her activism it's no
longer BLM and mostly peaceful riots and
looting and burning the country down now
she is a fat phobia activist and she's
being rewarded for that with presumably
a bunch of money and fame by Dove
my belief is that we should be centering
the voices and experiences of the most
marginalized people and communities at
all times so when I think about what fat
Liberation looks like to me it looks
like centering the voices and the
experiences of those who live in and who
maneuver through spaces and institutions
in a fat body it looks like making
accessible spaces and having
conversations that are aware of the fact
that people have different bodies and
that they are interacting with space and
people and institutions and communities
in a different way fat Liberation looks
like fully embracing those differences
and having those conversations instead
of shying away from them to learn more
about fat Liberation and the campaign
for size Freedom that Dove is supporting
visit dove.com siiz Freedom tap in join
the campaign support the campaign this
is important and we should all be
talking about it okay I'm not going to
make fun of fat Liberation and I'm not
gonna make fun of even Dove so much here
I want to focus on something
one word that that woman said and she
said it multiple
times
conversation this is what liberalism
does for liberalism the highest point of
politics is not doing anything it's not
changing anything it's not achieving a
concrete objective it's just having
endless
conversations when you hear a political
figure say we need a conversation we
need a national conversation on Race we
need a conversation on our democracy I
think it's time that we just it's so
important that we have conversations
about the ability to have conversations
while conversing about the significance
of
conversations that's what politics is
all about when you hear that kind of
talk you know that you are one hearing
from a liberal and two being deceived
you you're hearing from someone who
witing or unwillingly is is deceiving
you because endless
conversations don't do anything in
politics and in politics things have to
get done decisions have to be made
policies have to be implemented people
have to get in
line but that is contrary to the open
free floating conversational language of
liberalism man and so what happens in
practice is that the Liberals who
ostensibly want to depoliticize
everything stop coming to firm rigid
conclusions just kind of keep the
conversation open man what they end up
doing is they end up partnering with
people who are decidedly illiberal to
usually
secretly uh Implement their
agenda this is why the Liberals always
go soft on antifa antifa doesn't want to
have conversations when antifa shows up
to your event they're not there to talk
okay they're there to crack some skulls
and throw explosives at the venue and
kill people if they can BLM doesn't want
to talk BLM doesn't want to have
conversations BLM wants to steal the
microphone shout their
propaganda then cut the mic and start
looting stores and shaking down
businesses and seizing power and oh also
killing people that's that's what those
groups want to do and the Liberals can
pay lip service to how this has gone too
far and we don't like we don't we would
never do this
but they fund those groups they bail
those groups out of jail when when the
BLM riers finally did get arrested on
occasion kamla Harris bailed them out of
jail she didn't bail out the peaceful
protesters she bailed out the riers who
committed crimes Joe Biden's staff did
the the same thing they raised money to
bail these criminals out of prison
because the illiberal forces the hard
leftists and antifa and
BLM and outright Communists and outright
anarchists they do the dirty work for
the Li
and the Liberals get to pretend that
they're above politics no no we don't we
don't under we don't we don't view
Politics as a distinction between
friends and enemies we don't want to
force anybody to go along with our
program we just want to be open and
conversational but if you don't go along
with our program antifa is going to show
up at your door oh but they're not us no
we're totally different but hey antifa
when you do show up and crack some
skulls you're not going to be punished
for it that that
is such a ception even the very fact
that liberalism says we just have the
economic sphere we just have the social
sphere we have the Civil Society that's
not political that's not politics and
electoral offices and laws no it's just
the free market and the free
conversation and then meanwhile what
Dove Partners up with these radical
activists who who are not there to talk
to you do not beware beware the endless
conversation you know when Dr Jordan B
Peterson made the decision to join daily
War plus it was a major win for those
who Champion intellectual debate with
one year of unparalleled output his
contributions have set new standards and
remain unmatched by any other platform
dailywire plus now has a vast array of
exclusive Jordan Peterson content
offering hundreds of hours of
captivating content you won't find
anywhere else Jordan has created
thought-provoking works that reshape
your perspective on life which include
vision and Destiny marriage
and Dragons monsters and men and because
there are so many topics sometimes the
commas and the ANS get confusing I don't
even know how many shows that is
Additionally you can immerse yourself in
discussions that nurture your spiritual
side like logos and literacy in Jordan's
groundbreaking series on the book of
Exodus that's only the beginning I have
not even mentioned his Beyond order
lecture series well I guess now I just
did mention it I haven't even mentioned
his extensive Archive of lectures and
podcasts until now I just did mention
that this is the absolute compendium of
all things Jordan plus there's even more
exclusive content on the horizon this is
only the beginning become a daily War
plus member you will embark on an
unforgettable experience that will fuel
your thirst for knowledge and Inspire
personal growth like never before
dailywire.com subscribe become a member
today finally finally we've arrived at
my favorite time of the week when I get
to hear from you in the mailbag this
mailbag is sponsored by Pur talk go to
Pur
talk.com NOS kwes to save an additional
50% % off your first month take it away
hello hello there Puff Daddy uh John
here with a question for the daily wire
Love Guru uh earlier this summer I met
this fantastic young lady and she and I
have really hit it off um just one
example of something we have in common
you know both of our older brothers are
priests and they were actually ordained
together so she and I were actually at
the same ordination years ago before we
ever actually met each other which is
Small World um anyway I live in Alaska
and she's Mexican and I've been down
there to visit her once already and it
went great
um I'm just a little worried now that
you know the powers that be are starting
to foist the pestilence upon us again um
I managed to dodge the jab last time
around but I'm a little worried now like
what if they make the jab a requirement
for international
travel
[Music]
um I'm not sure how I would handle that
situation and I'm wondering how you
would um so what would you do if you
were in my shoes and you had to face
that situation all right thank you
first of all stop worrying look at the
lies of the field look at them more
resplendant than Solomon and all of his
glory yes they're trying to do Co again
to rig the 2024 election I it's true I
know I'll probably get in trouble with
Media Matters for saying that but it's
just so obviously true that they're
doing that now but there's no evidence
that they're going to implement these
the travel restrictions so I wouldn't
worry just keep keep your courtship
going and see how it goes uh but be
prepared for the hypothetical what would
you do in that case in that case I
[Music]
would the Bishops have said that it is
morally listed some of them have even
pushed the jab on people uh so you know
that's what
the authority of the church is saying
about this issue and I think you could
receive the jab basically with a clean
conscience because the authorities the
successors to the apostles have said so
however it is a remote cooperation with
evil there's no getting around that and
so maybe your conscience would bother
you maybe that would keep you up at
night first decide on that are you
willing as a moral matter to take the
jab then you've got the secondary
question which is well I don't think the
jab is good for me yeah fair or enough
it probably isn't uh I don't think that
I need the jab yeah you sound like a
young guy you don't need the jab well I
don't I don't like to be bullied by
these governments and by these
for the
girl if you're going to marry her
probably you would okay well if you're
going to take a bullet you'd probably
take the poison fouchy ouchy too even if
the worst case scenario happened so I I
wouldn't focus on the political issue I
would just focus on the moral issue do
you think it
[Music]
is okay next question hey Mike uh do you
think that the libs bringing back coid
will have a significant impact on the
landscape of the Republican primary
particularly for Ronda santis since
Shifting the focus back to co will
enable him to highlight his achievements
in Florida uh in point to Donald Trump's
decision to turn the country over to Dr
fouy curious in your thoughts it's his
best shot by far if you are on the
disantis
campaign from the perspective strictly
of self-interest you have got to be
praying that fouchy comes back and that
the coid lockdowns go back into effect
because if you look at this chart here
right nothing really has changed in as
much as there has been any change
DeSantis spiked and then he fell down
but if you look where he began and where
he is now he's just down a little bit
from where he was Trump is just up a
little bit from where he was I don't see
very much changing the race the the race
in the circumstances of this indictment
or this mugshot or this that or the
other thing seems so Dynamic already and
even with this dynamism the race is
totally flat so that that's the only
shot that DeSantis has but just looking
how nothing has changed basically for
any of the candidates in well over a
year I I wouldn't put my money on that
changing but
but if there is a shot for DeSantis it
is that one and DeSantis would be crazy
not to hammer him for it the problem for
disantis is he peaked too soon so he
peaked during coid and everyone loved
him during Co and they were all talking
about him as a potential Presidential
nominee but people's memories are so so
short so you would have to remind people
of it and and Co could help them even
then though I just think the race is
stabilized enough it's I I wouldn't
predict that it would make much of a
difference next question hi Mr NES this
is Abby a from the chat my question for
you is in regards to college because I'm
homeschooled I have a really big jump
start on my school this will be
considered my senior year of high school
and next year I will be eligible to
start dual enrollment once my two years
are up I have it planned out that I will
have accumulated around 60 college
credits if I were to continue on the
next 2 years I would have a bachelor's
degree in finance shortly after I turned
19 my question is is it worth spending
the time and money to complete my degree
if all I want to do is be a stay-at-home
mom and raise a family my dad says I
have to have a backup plan in case
something happens to my husband and I
need to have a way to support my family
I can't wait to hear your thoughts love
the show and keep up the good
work I generally disc discourage people
who are not sold on going to college
from going to college I am not one of
these conservatives many conservatives
will say oh don't go to college at all
it's totally bunk no if you are drawn to
go to college and you want to go for the
right reasons I encourage that I'm
certainly not one of these conservatives
who says if you do go to college you
should major in some practical degree
like a stem or something parts of stem
like engineering or some I I totally
disagree with that the point of
University education is to get a liberal
education it's not to do job training
you can do job training whenever later
on down the line the point of a
university education is to do things are
completely not practical at all to just
cultivate your uh rational will and to
uh read Dusty old books that will help
you to see the world more clearly um in
your
case you're saying you would want to get
this degree for a practical purpose
you're not particularly drawn to it but
because of the way your schooling has
already worked you would you would
essentially get a college degree in one
year
I I don't know are you engaged to be
married right now if you are engaged to
be married and your husband is I don't
know he's in the Navy or something and
you're going to get married and then
he's going to deploy and you're going to
move all over the country and it would
make going to college very very
difficult then may okay maybe you get
married and start having kids whatever
if you're not engaged to be married
though if you don't have the prospect of
this wedding anytime soon and and you've
just got a year where you don't know
exactly what you're going to do with it
I don't why not I don't I don't think
it's bad to have a backup plan uh I
wouldn't I wouldn't put off the life
that you want to live for this life that
liberal modernity pushes you into or so
that you have a plan B but it doesn't
sound like you would be pushing off that
life some people do some people push it
off four years of college then maybe
couple years of an of a higher degree or
even a PhD and then a long time of a
career and then they don't even start
thinking about settling down until
they're 30 that's not the situation you
were in so practically I don't know if
you're not doing anything else with the
year might as well pick up a finance
degree next
question hey Michael it's Camille again
and yes I'm still single and before you
say just take my advice and settle I
need you to understand that I have been
trying Michael it's not for lack of
trying and no I'm not out there
desperate and no I'm not out there picky
everyone says that when a girl who's
still single and 29 is just picky that
just is not the case these quality of
men is just not that high so I need some
advice like how do I actually find
someone I like and I swear if you tell
me to settle I may have to unsubscribe
and change my badge I I might have to do
it so please give me any good advice
where I can find a guy to settle down
and not
settle you need to go to the places
where the men that you want to marry
will be and then you need to be the sort
of person who would be married by the
men you want to marry both of those
things are very
important and I'm not saying you can't
be that person and I'm not saying you
don't know where those places are but I
think if you have those two ingredients
that's going to
help so I've got I have a great deal of
sympathy here I don't want to sound like
I'm being too harsh
but are you are you going to church
maybe you don't believe in God or
something okay well if you don't if you
don't believe in God or if you don't
practice religion then you're you're
probably not going to meet a guy who
does believe in God and does practice
religion and the kind of guy you want to
marry is the kind of guy who has
religion so right right there off the
bat that's going to be a problem for you
if you are
not regularly attending church and doing
these sorts of things you're not going
to be in the place with those kind of
guys that you want to meet and you're
not going to be the kind of person that
those guys are going to want to marry
that's the F first stop right off the
bat are you what are you doing in your
free time how are you even going about
meeting these men are you just going on
dating apps are you just like going to
the bar or you just going out you know
to the downtown pubs or something or
nightclubs or or are you talking to
friends and saying hey can you set me up
with this person what kind of friends
are you talking to to to set you up are
you talking to married stable normal
friends who are who have already figured
this stuff out or are you just spending
time hanging out with your girlfriends
who are in the same boat that you are
which isn't I I don't know your
situation Camille but I do know that
I've had many female friends who have
been in this situation and they've
turned it around but they they the way
that they've turned it around is not by
continuing to do the same thing over and
over again saying there's just no guys
out there there are guys out there but
are you going to the place places where
they are and if you do go to where they
are that's that's a big First Step are
you the kind of
person that they would want to marry men
are not nearly as shallow as we are told
that we are you know we've got red blood
we like nicelooking ladies we you know
we like all of those things but when men
think about getting married dating for
marriage they're thinking about is this
someone I want to live with for the rest
of my life even after all of our looks
everyone's looks are going to fade at
some point is this someone I want to be
with is this someone I want to raise my
children is this someone who sees the
world in the same way that I do and
sometimes for some of my friends who
have dealt with this they
have continued to live like big Libs
they have continued to see the world
actually as big Libs but then they say I
want to marry a guy who's a good strong
traditional conservative normal a good
husband type well that's not going to
happen you've you've got to be the sort
of person and do the sort of things that
would attract that person which you can
do it's not that hard it doesn't require
a magic spell you just got to do kind of
basic stuff and that will start to what
that will start to do is not only value
of the opportunity to meet these guys it
will change your desire it will begin to
turn your desire
toward men who maybe right now you are
not attracted to maybe you're still
attracted to the big jerk idiot Bad Boys
even though you say that you're not a
lot of women they just are they just
continue to be like that your desires
will start to change and you will be
more attracted to the guys for whom you
right now are suggesting you might have
to settle the rest of the show continues
now you don't want to miss this become a
member with use code n k has a check out
for two months for all annual
plans where's my
[Music]
iPad